what if I drink coffee like this what if
I drink coffee like this playing in real
life you probably choke and die
no man's sky next is out Mike
Robert Michael Peter Rob we played a
whole bunch of ed last few days I
personally still can't grasp everything
about this update to name a few
third-person don't like player yeah
graphical enhancements you looking at
your screen doesn't convince me you've
actually played the game but okay it's I
personally been very excited about it
it's crazy it's crazy it okay I won't
say I won't go as far as to say it feels
like a whole new game because as we
discussed amongst ourselves you still
have to be comfortable just grinding out
the mining right and doing the Minecraft
stuff right like so it's not a totally
different game that's still very
important but I mean let's break it down
if you will the third-person stuff to me
really helps like solidify my context
like Who I am how big I am and his grand
scheme I felt it before but like not
being able to see me never felt like I
really got the full picture now I feel
like okay I get this I am super super
lonely I get that more than ever and I
get to see people now yeah I know you
even just that the animations look
pretty great like all the emotes and
stuff you can do you know you have the
very much destiny esque
and multiple ways I reminds me of that
like but the Space Station's are not
just a door with the same cut and paste
room it's a communal like market with
all these merchants and you know you're
able to kind of interact in that in the
funny way is I'm just like I'm choking
I'm jumping up and down like all that's
very fluid in it looks great
maybe I'm jumping topics too soon but I
want to talk about multiplayer because
that was one thing that people were
really excited about two years ago I
mean like obviously that was a big
marketing fiasco what happened what
didn't happen what what was no man skies
part what was Sony's fault but
multiplayer was a cool aspect you
running into someone randomly in this
seemingly and in this infinite universe
just running into someone that alone
just seems like you know miraculous and
then when people finally did they
couldn't see each other but now there's
multiplayer and that's that's great but
I was talking to you about this this
morning I feel like multiplayer now that
I've finally come to grips with one no
man sky is and like being chill and calm
with it and you know the Minecraft
aspects I feel like once the initial
thrill of multiplayer war off it was
actually grating to play with other
people for me and I realized that might
be very personal to me but I felt like
that was kind of the antithesis of what
I should be doing this game no no so
you're totally right it is the
antithesis because so much of being
alone and lost in this universe is
really buying into it and feeling like a
part of it being patient and kind of by
yourself sure right and the idea of
running into someone randomly is just
like what are the odds yeah now it's
literally like you join someone's game
it takes you from wherever you are and
puts you on that person's in that system
with them so it's already fundamentally
changing like your relationship with the
game but I think it's not to begins
judgment like I think no man's sky can
exist as either or sure either the
single-player pursuit where maybe you're
chasing the awakening quest or the Alice
path or you just want an excuse to like
fly your ship around and look cool and
show off for people and goof off and
that's what I'm getting playing with
these you know playing with with Rob and
a bit of Josh and stuff it's just it
really feels like a playground for us
rather than a journey that I'm going on
because we're not getting [ __ ] done
that's oh there's way too much to do
that was the that was what we kind of
realized later last night and then even
today confirming the fact that it is a
playground but at some point you got to
pick something to do and to it like in
looking at the reddit it's like okay
someone was saying like the one of the
best things to do as far as like you
know bang for your buck getting a lot of
units is going to a planet
landing on Planet setting up a signal
booster and then finding these ruins in
all the ruins there's some buried
treasure
essentially you dig that up and you flip
it and you get a lot of money we tried
doing that and sure enough friends -
like a brick wall were like there was no
treasure there was no anything and
that's a letdown because it's very much
like a kids game to me in some ways
where it's like you can get immediately
lost in segue into a different thing
like let's cool mine over here I need to
get war fuel to get off this planet I
need to do this everyone has different
goals sometimes something just looks
beautiful sometimes it's just a cool
Vista yeah and you go and you want to go
do that it I guess I'm trying to get at
is with the simple implementation of
multiplayer there's also a need to like
be very constructive in what your goals
are and what you want to do and that
even doubts back to the base building
aspects which are pretty neat but once
again there are some bugs that are
littered in it but you need to be sure
everyone's on the same page cuz you're
you're all working for the same goal but
someone needs to step in I want to say
sometimes and be like okay like what are
we actually building here or just agree
that hey we don't have a goal in mind
just screen around like you said
multiplayer they can exist alongside
each other and I think they do well
because you don't have to be playing
multiplayer I still prefer the game as
this solitary experience where find a
plan to explore it I get off planet I do
another warp drive I go to the next star
cluster and I accept that everything I'm
seeing is fleeting
whereas in multiplayer it's like
show-and-tell and you want to build a
base and settle down on this home planet
and you could do that in single-player
but I feel like there's more there's
less impetus to keep exploring and
multiplayer if only because the people
I'm playing with our very tend to be
disorganized or something and you know
like it's just fun to mess around to be
in the same world as someone else right
I mean the thing is you can still exist
in the same system in the same instance
you can travel to a different system
yeah and still talk to each other yeah
right and meet up again so there are
ways where you can splinter off and go
do your own thing and then come back now
that we haven't really done too much of
that but that's sort of is a very
interesting concept in my mind where we
have set up a base and we treat it as
such like literally like we will always
return here at the end of whatever play
session whether we're together or not
and this will be our foundation yeah but
we can do our own things as long as we
contribute to something we haven't tried
to define what that something is yet I
know like you and Jacob built a base and
now josh is trying to build it you know
his base so you said like in the trees
behind it okay it's kinda like it's so
funny to see like wooden texture cabins
with like a hologram entrance yeah so
maybe we all do that for a while right
we all build out establish this presence
gets to another planet really well the
planets around it but at some point if
we want to keep doing that we'll have to
say okay do we take a step back and
reformulate this base because we
understand so much of the possibilities
now what do we want to do that's bigger
I don't think we can see the big picture
benefits of multiplayer yet it's only
been a couple days and it just feels
like there's so much to wrap your head
around yeah you started a fleet so that
was that's exactly as my most important
aspect to me personally there's a lot
going on with that and the previous game
they had the implementation of
freighters now you can like straight up
manage your fleet with upwards I think
the 60 other frigates so I had this
really cool moment where you know you in
the game you run across like space
pirates who scan your ship didn't find
something valuable they pull you add a
pulse
jump and attack you it was really neat
to basically have that going on and be
like oh yeah
say hello to my little friend yeah warp
in a frigate and whisset came a smaller
forget that like was of the many at
different aspects of stats specialized
in combat and deploy these subsequent
freaking fighters and it's now to touch
space back
you can imagine the great the grander
scheme of life okay I'm gonna put a lot
of time with more frigates get more
forgettin and come across not just AI
but Larry another player so but then
have the space battle but the thing is
that you have to elect how you do
multiplayer you either open yourself up
to randoms right and that would be the
pool where people run into each other or
you play with friends given the
experience of the past two years at this
game
I'm inclined to think most people are
gonna choose to play with friends
because then they know they can
guarantee they'll be playing with
somebody when they want to be I'm a
little worried that the joint anyone's
game thing no one's gonna do that
because are you really gonna run into
someone so we were talking also about
like I wanted I was saying in that last
video I would really want to be a pirate
and mess with people and be a troll but
then we were saying how would you do
that because if you join someone else's
game and do that they can easily just
kick you not even just that will suck on
the sub rest you start seeing that is
that people are actually doing just that
apparently yes the hosel only kicking
them maybe they don't know how to or
it's a problem I even thought I saw some
and said that he was able to like turn
it off actually and go like solo maybe
that's the base sharing aspect of it
maybe I'm not quite sure but this guy
was saying there like people were coming
in and just attacking him non-stop as he
was trying to get off the planet or
another guy he was in like I was trying
to help a person get a planet because
some [ __ ] was prohibiting him from
fixing his initial starter fighter
were you talking to me about like
abandoned stations or like spaceships
and stuff that people are showing up and
it's just like a ghost town yeah so
that's the other cool part about this
update is that there's a lot I want to
call them scenes or scenarios it seems
like you know everything from what you
were saying where there was like these
like kind of like monochromatic planets
where yeah the light spectrum is only
limiting like red yeah black white and
red and that's it that's so cool it's
really cool-looking he's got cool photos
by the way the subreddit is fantastic
there are so many awesome images that
people are able to capture and toss up
its ring firing stuff it is it's like I
want to get back in this game
yeah yeah exactly the other cool stuff
is yeah someone was saying that there
are like not just derelict like space
stations but derelict systems where the
presence of Atlas and just in general
species of aliens aren't even present
like it is just barren which seems
pretty neat like landing on a space
station and there's no one there yeah
that's a possibility the other one is
especially they're these things called
the whispering eggs this is a weird name
in general whispering eggs if you
interact with them these xenomorph zerg
like aliens come out and apparently it's
like two hits and you're dead so they're
horrifying
this is just conveniently interesting
bug pun intended
you just get stuck on the glass cuz he's
like jumping on them the canopy it's
horrifying but that's cool and these
eggs are apparently like very expensive
and you can like flip them and get a lot
of money out of it I think it's I mean
for all of Mike's complaints about
multiplayer which I don't think we
disagree with I think it's just that
there's so much so many different ways
of looking at this game yeah I also
don't like people so that's true but to
my point I think I'm actually like
really enthused by what I'm seeing so
far in the update and I'm still I'm
excited for this game all over again
yeah so that was my question do you
think like you mentioned I don't think
this is a completely new game maybe it's
like no man's sky 1.3 woo yeah it's not
a review score that's just what I know
what you dig it out B so this this
changed my mind on the game for sure
personally because
especially when I'm playing
single-player and I'm coming back to it
and kind of coming to grips with the
fact that a lot of what I'm seeing is
bleeding and I'm not settling down maybe
that's why I haven't enjoyed multiplayer
as much because I'm not showing off a
base or I'm not showing off a fleet
although I would like to build a fleet
for sure I think it changed my mind on
the game I don't feel like it's a whole
new game but did you guys feel as if you
think this will bring back people who
didn't really like no man's sky and I
think it every 16 yeah I think yes I
think I think it's I think you could
even strip away the multi player and
it's still a far better game a far
better like polished game I mean they
wiped all the elements and ran rebalance
all that stuff granted it's you know
more difficult and more minecraft es to
like find warp fuel now is like another
two steps which is interesting and that
kind of treats everything differently
right you have to like rethink how you
do things in this game which I want to
say is one part of like why this this
feels so different but the other thing
is like you look at the wildlife you
don't see so many of these just
abominations they seem to be better
looking animals and I would even say
that they also are to quote Jurassic
Park like they're moving in herds and
stuff like they're not so like
individualistic where they just start
like randomly like walking around and
stuff like you're seeing groups of
animals and the animations of these
things look a lot better yeah there's
like the best parts about this game have
been improved and they've introduced new
things that are really good I don't know
what else we could really ask for yeah I
mean we're still trying to figure out
what the hell this is so maybe we'll
know more yeah that being said I'm very
excited and I will continue to play and
it's neat it's neat to see this game
have this Second Coming like it's
fascinating and they were able to do it
I mean it's been two years they could
have ditched it right they could have
just like hid but here they are back
again they're owning the story of this
game yeah more power - that's awesome
[Music]